hello folks how's everybody i hope
you're doing better to me
i'm a little sick
today
and for the last four or five days i've
had a runny nose a little bit of a runny
nose and sneezing lots of sneezing
and i don't know why but i think it's
got to do with the uh
shot i got in the arm the other day
i think it's maybe maybe my body's
reacting to the
poison they put in my arm
so uh
if i sneeze uh you know why okay other
than that i'm i'm doing okay
so uh let's continue today the show must
go on and uh what we do here for those
of you who are new we do a little bit of
extinction first
we're going to talk about the extinction
of man
and all subjects which are related to
that
uh then we're gonna do a little bit of
physics today is the last installment
of uh transparency and opacity i'm gonna
touch upon one more subject before we
leave the subject and
and then i'm going to open the floor for
questions people who
asked questions since last time
okay so let's move on here let's do
extinction here i had a little bit of a
headline it's got to do with china okay
and china's a big deal and i
especially in the world
stage today
and uh the way i look at it um
you know china is not going to become
the next empire the united states will
be the last empire that's how close we
are to extinction
and
and so yeah i look at china very closely
because i think it's
it's the last major region of the world
that needs to be
needs to develop economically once it
does
reach that plateau
then i think that's also
a
a stopping point for humanity i think
that's that's where humanity somewhat
ends when the united states does not
grow anymore and china
also reaches some kind of plateau and i
don't think there's much more
time after that
okay so here's china says u.s and eu the
european union agree to work on chip
supplies tech rules china trade they're
all worried about china
and says a statement in the
in the body of this article says the
statement did not mention china but said
we stand together in continuing to
protect our businesses consumers and
workers from unfair trade practices they
want to contain who china
in particular those posed by non-market
economy
economies uh or economics or the
economics i said it right the first time
uh why because they're they say that
china's not playing
uh fair ball
uh that are undermining the world
trading system
so uh these countries are a little
worried about china and um
and this is sponsored this these
uh meetings are sponsored by the united
states because the united states is not
growing
or not growing fast enough
while china is still growing and that's
a worry for a lot of people especially
in the united states
government
they're worried about this china rising
and catching up and what are we going to
do about it
and
so they look for ways to stop china and
one of those is to say oh you're
cheating you're doing this you're
subsidizing your private companies and
uh you know competing on the world
stage with companies like ours which are
not subsidized
you know that sort of thing
and so uh
some of it seems to be nitpicking
because i think every country in the
world subsidizes to some degree some
industry in its country united states
for sure subsidizes many agricultural
products for example to keep their
farmers you know
going
sometimes it buys
from those farmers when the world market
collapses or whatever so that the
farmers can continue
rolling until next year and so on so
every country essentially subsidizes and
i think that's more or less what the
chinese throw back at the united states
and at the western union
europe
but yeah right now there's this these
two worlds
okay
we have uh the world of china and its
allies on its side and the united states
and its allies on its side and the
question is whether
that's going to read some
special climax
okay
fellow ass in relation to that says i
guess china's on a lot of people's minds
what are your thoughts on the russian uh
chinese military drills just in case
america decides to keep going
imperialistic around the south china
seas okay
i personally think that there won't be a
war we are essentially in a cold war too
okay
no way america is moralized to fight
another war if it keeps losing the third
world armed to third world countries
like vietnam and afghanistan so
frequently
um
it's not that they lost
in america lost in in afghanistan
a lot of that has to do with you know
how much are you willing to invest and
what are you going to get out of it how
strategic is
afghanistan and when they do their
calculations they say look it's not
worth it
especially when you have russia and
china
which take advantage of that say oh
let's let's compel the americans to
spend lots of money lots of energy lots
of
you know resources on fighting
these uh
barefooted uh hillbillies from
afghanistan
and they spend all this money you know
to to fight them and we can keep that
going as far as the americans want so
that's what it's all about so it's
question of resources and i think the
united states has opted for abandoning
afghanistan and taking some of those
resources
and taking them
further east where they think they have
a more um
important situation
and i think that's what's happening and
likewise i think that i mentioned in the
past that they've abandoned
saudi arabia
so it's like the united states is moving
its pawns on the chess game
over to the east it's taking its
resources farther east i think that's
what it's all about so it's not like
they lost against the afghanistan he's
i'm sure the united states
could have done a lot more there but
they just said it's not worth it even if
we bomb them the smithereens what are we
gonna get nothing
so
it's a question is what you get out of
it what you put in what you get out
and so i just want to point out
also what this dichotomy is about this
fight between the east and the west okay
and here's a little picture that
summarizes this more or less okay you
have china which is really a union it's
got a single government okay
uh whereas this alliance i'll call it
the confederation
uh involves the united states european
union united kingdom australia canada
primarily the english-speaking countries
that's why i put those
the european union in um
in purple there because we don't really
know if all those countries are reliable
as
as um
allies military and economic uh allies
everyone has their own interests each
one of those countries that form the
european union has its own government
and they don't always agree to go along
with whatever policy the united states
dictates
that's not the case in china where china
there's only one government and it tells
the people what to do okay
and you can see the difference in
population china has 1.4 billion people
and all these others put together
you know this com federation has doesn't
even reach a billion
and so the question is whether um
not only that you have fewer population
but you have also um
the fact that they're not united they're
not completely united in their efforts
against china right now they get they
have a military
and economic superiority and the
question is how long is that going to
last okay is china coming up to speed
becoming mightier
it's got money for example to spend in
africa it's also so intervening in some
countries in the in in the americas like
you know venezuela and and cuba
so it's it's trying to expand its empire
as well
you know and the question is
uh
will the united states at some point
have to provoke
a war
more like most likely because of taiwan
uh in order to stop china's growth and
create an incident that will lead to war
okay
so these are things that you have to
think about and uh one of those is that
whether
europe will go along with with such a
war like you know they they might follow
the united states at some point to some
point but at some point
they're going to stop and say well this
we're not going to cross this line okay
and i more or less put those countries
down on the bottom uh
according to their population that's why
canada is so small because canada only
has 38 million people and australia
there yeah it's got only 26 million
people china has 1.4 billion people
so there's a big difference between the
the population of these countries okay
so keep all that in mind uh for any
future reference it's good to have a
notion of
first the population
and then the fact that china is really
has a single government for
1.4 billion people that's not the case
for the west the west is a confederation
and if the u.s civil war is
serves as an indicator uh we know what
happened to the com federation it broke
apart
okay
so uh i don't know these are things that
you gotta ponder
okay here uh just another
version or vision of this it's uh again
the alliances okay and you see the uh
political uh economic military alliances
um
that
have been taking place
everybody's you know moving their pawns
on the chessboard one guy moves it this
way the other guy moves it that way and
these are just uh very
general
you know hot spots that are out there
they're obviously more alliances than
this okay
but let's just give you a little
snapshot okay quick snapshot of how the
alignments are taking place
and
the question is whether these two groups
are going to come and clash at some
point in time
okay things for you to ponder uh will
there be war
uh
is there any other way to stop china
china is still growing like five or six
percent the united states not even close
it's maybe one or two percent i don't
even know if it's growing at all
the other thing is that the united
states is growing
also
its
services it's not growing any real
manufacturing let alone agriculture
and you know again i like to distinguish
those because
real stuff is the tangible stuff in in
the case of uh economics when you
construct uh bridges when you construct
streets
uh cars
uh airplanes houses
you know highways uh
even fields that you plant all that's
tangible and that's a measure of wealth
uh all this services stuff that's all
abstract and all we're doing is moving
money around
we're not really creating anything new
until that money somehow goes into
manufacturing or into agriculture where
something
uh tangible is produced okay so
until something tangible is produced all
you did was move money around
okay and so i say that services is
unemployment masked unemployment and i
say that services is uh misleading
you know when you've grown services and
all the economies in the west are trying
to not only are already in the service
mode 80 85 percent of their economies
are services
what is that
you know what have they constructed what
have they what is what have they made
that is real okay
and the issue is nothing services is not
real economy okay it's a mass economy
okay uh here we have um another fellow
says it's not marxism that is going to
blow up it's conservative or right-wing
socialism what's called the nazbal
ideology okay i guess the ball for the
bolsheviks okay
and yeah it's like the ultra right and
the ultra left somehow shake hands or
have a meeting of the minds
okay that's i guess what he's suggesting
fascists and marxists are starting to
realize that there's a connection
between private interests and cultural
liberalism
while it's true that marxists have
supported egalitarianism so have the
capitalists okay capitalists love mass
migration lgbt feminism and
individualism
uh these are uh i get
political comments uh
what we try to do here is to
relate this stuff to extinction we're
interested in extinction not just in
politics we bring politics economics
military uh issues
only in in the context of you know
extinction so try to
keep it within the context of this
channel okay
we don't do politics here or do as
little as we can
possibly manage we're interested in the
issue of extinction how all these
different branches of our society
eventually end up
affecting or accelerating or
or decelerating extinction the process
of extinction okay
okay uh
fellow says
enemies cooperate okay says you claim
enemies can't cooperate yeah i say they
don't
they do under certain circumstances i
guess that's what you're going to refer
to here once a state of mutually assured
destruction exists between nations why
do they cooperate to limit the size of
nuclear arsenals and allow mutual
overflight rights
okay
uh good point answer to make things
mutually better rather than worse if
they all benefit they will all cooperate
okay so uh suggesting that uh the
russians the chinese especially those
two countries and the united states you
know at the top levels uh
they shake hands
uh
you know
down at the bottom uh they don't care uh
they say
you know let people think whatever they
want
and we at the top we all agree we're all
part of the same club
so to speak right so that they're not
really enemies at the top
and all i'm gonna clarify there is that
you know you keep in mind like world war
one you had uh
uh wilhelm uh the first of uh uh germany
uh the second i think it was the second
half uh and he was a cousin of the
british guy right george
and you know they were all
in fact family extended family and
you know they they did visit each other
and they sent letters to each other
and yet there was a what we call world
war one there was a fighting between all
these countries the military of one
country
fighting against the military of another
country even though the people at the
top
shook hands
okay so keep that in mind uh the fact
that people shake hands at the top
does not mean that the military of those
countries and the economic forces
uh
political
as well right uh do not
try to create some incident because of
interest
that does not concern really the people
who rule it's it's other people also who
have interests and move their pawns in
such a way that it creates a situation
irrespective of what the people at the
top think
okay
or can do
i'm not sure all these
emperors that we have today you know the
emperor in the united states yepper and
russia the emperor in china all these
emperors you know they have limited
power because there's other people who
also have interests within those
countries and those interests don't
always match
okay so
to treat this as a monolithic uh
thing up at the top saying all the
people here in china at the top agree
with all the people on the top in the
united states i agree with everyone on
the top in russia that's where i have a
difference with them okay anyways he
said we're assuming the heads of state
really are enemies i think it's the
other way around they could be friends
but the enemies are the people
immediately under them who where where
the power is distributed okay so you
have the military over here the
politicians over there who we might even
hate the emperor you know
whoever's the emperor at the time
and you know those people move their
forces
uh irrespective of what the head of
state really believes or wants to do
okay
and aren't cooperating to maintain the
illusion of being enemies okay fear of
invasion can justify control over the
masses and a hierarchy of wealth power
okay
and all i can say is a little anecdote
that i've got from cuba when i was in
cuba they told me a little uh
saying they have and they said that um
they say that they called the the meat
you know the meat meat is very scarce on
the island even to this day and it
doesn't come very often comes like every
six months or whatever and so people you
know
just pray and hope that maybe meat will
come someday right and so they called
the meat
they call the meat the yankees
you say what are you calling them
yankees well because the government
always tells us they're coming they're
coming they're almost here
and we never see them
so that's more or less
what this guy says as well you know
uh you know they they say look there's
an enemy out there we have to be strong
and whatever and people say hell yeah
let's all work together because there's
gonna be this invasion and the invasion
never comes
and so yeah uh in that sense he's right
uh the masses are manipulated
and there's not much the masses can do
because they have no ruling power okay
no no real power is up
so yeah uh we have to be careful about
all that
okay here's uh
thou says changing a little bit the
subject here the problem with equality
between men and women is that it always
starts with a white male standard
women are just as strong as men blacks
are just as good as whites but there is
no reason to buy into
this standard in the first place
okay
um
all i can say is you know
some people
are like i mentioned the other day last
time is that um especially some men you
know they're worried about women
catching up
it's like you know you women belong in
the kitchen
uh kind of taliban sort of thing and so
you know i'd like to point out a
situation and that situation is that
you know you have women out there who
are
into very heavy sports like rustling and
weight lifting and so on which are
have traditionally
been
almost uh
uniquely for men
and now we have women going into those
sports women play soccer
i think they play american football i
don't know i don't watch uh female
american football i do watch american
football with men okay
but uh the question is uh you know that
i said remove
the
the sex issue make it all unisex make
everybody compete against everybody else
okay
and
so women eventually will have to come up
to par with the best men
and maybe they will come up to par with
the best man
and it won't be in this issue whether
they have testosterone or estrogen you
know maybe maybe that's not the deciding
factor maybe it's the fact that women
have been uh kept by men down for so
many years they did do you know there
was this division of labor they were in
the kitchen men were out hunting and you
know that's changed quite a bit today
there is very little difference between
what women do and what men do
and as time goes by maybe there won't be
any difference in the quality and the
quantity and the
records that we set maybe females uh run
faster than men in the end if we give
them enough time not only will they
catch up maybe they even pass us
you know and we're long gone
from the days uh where you know you had
the huns or the what is it the uh
the uh hordes from the east uh genghis
khan
and they would sweep through little
villages uh kill the men raped the women
take their children as slaves you know
that sort of thing
and
that's a long time ago i mean
[Laughter]
we we can only see that in history and
in the movies and these days you know
you don't really see that
like we like it happen in those days
and you know i got a little anecdote
here uh just to show you that how um
how men used to
uh
or how many men think of these things
and it goes to this fellow from the
bible okay abimelech and as in judges it
says and certain women cast a piece of a
millstone upon abimelech's head and all
to break his skull
and then he called hastily unto the
young man his armor bearer and said unto
him draw thy sword and slay me
that men that men say not of me a woman
slew him
and his young man uh thrust him through
and he died
uh it was uh very embarrassing for a man
to be killed by a woman so the guy says
no no
just before i die you kill me
and that's more or less uh what's in the
mind of a lot of these uh folks out
there they think it's an issue of um
of women catching up and they being uh
embarrassed by the fact that a woman is
just as good or even better than them
uh
and they've got some
problem with that obviously okay and all
i'm saying is you know you take a
wrestler like maybe ronda rousey i'm
sure she could beat up a lot of men out
there
even heavier than bigger than she is
because she's a trained uh martial arts
uh
uh
fighter okay
uh she's been doing that since she was a
little kid okay and so you know um
that's reality
and you have to kind of
bow down to reality reality is reality
and then you know just in case as a
reference you'll see that there are
animals such as the hyena where the
female is bigger and mightier than the
males
and they have their harem really it's
not a harem it's a matriarchy right all
these females go around and the
male has to come in and ask for
permission you know
to do his thing and then he's got to
leave and if he doesn't leave well he's
in trouble with a big
female of the clan
because it's a clan run by females
elephants the same thing except the
elephant is bigger than elephant male
who's bigger than the elephant female
but
uh he's he's a loner and it's the when
you see several uh
elephants
they're all female they're all females
and they have their kids there when the
kids grow a little too big if they're
male they've got to leave the the clan
so you know um
you know i think also the spiders the
black widow
uh you know you have uh in the animal
world there are cases where the females
are stronger and bigger than the males
and i never asked any of those animals
they have estrogen or testosterone okay
but uh yeah it's uh it's not always the
case where male is bigger we do have uh
this dimorphism in you know on on
under
uh all kinds of monkeys apes and so on
but the question is are we an exception
where you know females are catching up
and eventually we'll become bigger and
stronger than men
i know a lot of people shudder at the
thought
a lot of men
okay let's continue here um
phil says after singles comes cloning
because i said okay we went from these
group sex that we had in the hunter
gathering days
maybe for almost 200 000 years then we
went into agriculture where we invented
this patriarchy where the male was the
head of the household he could do
anything with anyone in in the household
he was also responsible for them like if
one of your kids did something to your
neighbor you were responsible for that
and so on down the line okay and you
also had to defend them
like you know if your neighbor raped
your slave girl and maybe you
you did something about it and you know
you took that up with the council or
whatever so
you were responsible okay and that was
kind of like the what the patriarchy was
all about
uh then we went into the nuclear family
you know in the manufacturing age and
today we're in the service economy and
what we have singles bachelors most
people
just have maybe casual sex and then
separate after
uh length of time maybe three four years
and they separate each one goes his own
way and there is no uh family no real
family there's no kids
maybe there's one kid here and there
spends time with the mother maybe with a
father but it's really a singles society
we're moving into a single society we're
abandoning the
nuclear family right now it's dying okay
so the fellow says uh well the next step
is you know cloning maybe do some test
tube baby stuff women get their
kicks at the uh sperm bank
uh men uh hire some
tummy out there to do their job for them
okay
uh yeah it's it's a weird society now
we're really into weird things to have
what mother nature said look it's very
simple you just get together with a
woman you can have a baby you can have
many with her maybe have many with
several women you know and that's dying
because women
many of women don't want to have babies
anymore
especially if there's no long-term
relationship okay and so the singles is
destroying the
the birth of new children someone might
have a kid here and there but in general
the people who are still populating the
earth are those people who are living in
the nuclear age and they're still having
kids out there but again it's like i say
it's got to do with moving to the cities
once you move to the cities kids are out
okay no more kids you can't have 10 kids
in an apartment like we used to have 10
kids in the farms okay that's changed
for several reasons
okay and i do want to add one more time
that it was the um
rich
who used to have kids everybody
associates
having children with poor people
not true not completely true to some
degree it is true but in the old days it
was like this you know it was the filthy
rich who have kid who had kids okay in
the 19th century they had big families
and there was no problem with having
kids it was a different culture
it had to do with other reasons social
and economic
and you know here's a graph that really
puts this in context okay um
let me show you this
and here it is okay let me get back in
here
and who had children in the 19th century
well it wasn't the africans
okay it was the white
anglo-saxons you know people like me
we had children in the 19th century well
i have children but i have three boys
but so i did my duty for the fatherland
okay but it was uh the white folk europe
and uh
the americas they had children and
because they were countries that were
coming up
and
primarily in the north and they were
building cities and those cities were
manufacturing centers that's why
population increased drastically in
europe and in the united states
especially during the 19th century
because these were economies that were
expanding okay and they were feeding one
fed the other as people moved to the
cities that were not yet cities they
were growing cities there was
manufacturing there was economics
people still had kids they had the
agriculture mentality still so they were
coming in there having children there
was room for for children they had
houses not apartments okay nobody had
apartments in the 19th century it was
all houses
and so it was still
more or less rural just rural
mentality and rural um
society
and so that's when the population
increased and who were the europeans and
the americans they were the rich people
who were expanding
and by rich i mean you know wealthier
than people in africa who were the
africans well they were the ones that
were you know uh kidnapped as slaves and
taken to work in the fields they were
living in a in a different era in many
african countries they were in the
tribal world they were still
hunter-gatherers
and you can't have children a
hunter-gathering society it's not many
because you don't you have you don't
have enough resources to support them
you know the neanderthals they they were
always a small population because they
were hunter-gatherers and when crow
magnum came into europe he had small
populations because again
uh it's a hunter gathering society does
not allow for
billions of people
okay
and hopefully you can understand that
it's when you go into agriculture and
then manufacturing and that transition
that's when you start having children by
the tons
especially if you've conquered endemic
diseases which usually comes in parallel
with that because now you look at
you know your standard of living what
kind of
environment you have you start cleaning
the rivers you start
coming in contact with diseases so you
study them you find out how to kill
those diseases how to defend yourself
against them and once you conquer them
well now you can live more people can
live longer because of that okay so it's
all part of the same deal but that's why
the population increased in europe
because
you know
essentially
what happened in europe was the the
wealthy countries were having children
and they were having children because
they had a rural mentality the cities
were still rural in many ways they had
houses not not apartments and then there
was work
so there was economics there was a hope
for the future
and so they had children and they were
still not covered by social security
social security comes uh i think it was
um otto von blismark who was the first
one to implement social security
retirement that was uh around 1870 the
time of the uh
german french war
so that's when social security comes
around before then you had this
population expansion in part because
what the kids had to take care of their
parents there was no social security and
you had something to bequeath to them so
all these things kind of work together
to increase the population of europe and
united states what happened later on
well you can see it kind of leveled off
and now europe if anything is in many
parts in kind of
negative growth it's not producing the
number of children it should
uh produce it's not negative growth in
the sense that the total population is
decreasing but the
rate is what's falling okay
in that sense you know you have to be
careful that if the rate falls and falls
below zero well then you have a negative
growth and now you
now your pop your total population
starts decreasing what happened to
africa well it was after 1950s that
africans started having
seven eight nine ten children
why because again they went from
hunter-gatherers from being colonized to
countries that slowly gained their
independence until around 1960s
and that's when they started having
cities coming you know um into the
civilized world if we're going to caught
that that's when they started having
kids they they went from that transition
from hunter gathering to what to
agriculture and manufacturing
and creating cities
okay so so those trends give you an idea
that
the rich people did have children okay
and by rich i mean you know middle class
people who could afford to have children
had nothing really to do with money and
had to do more with
the transition from hunter gathering to
agriculture and from agriculture to
manufacturing we stopped having children
when when we started having services
okay services killed the the family
and part of that has to do with again
the fact that
we built
apartments instead of houses
and
the cities became mega cities you know
we have
millions of people in some cities
20 million 25 million today
those are big ant holes
you can't have many children in an ant
hole
okay
not the same rate as you had them in the
farms
okay
um here's a
last issue it's got to do with the
definition of life fellow says life is
defined as any atomic system capable of
performing functions such as eating
metabolizing excreting breathing moving
growing reproducing responding to
external stimuli
but see if we look at
the wikipedia in fact you'll see this
many places i just put wiki as as a main
reference
there's currently no consensus regarding
the definition of life
these are not
this whole thing here that this felt put
is not the definition of life
with this uh
mechanism this uh definition we can't
tell not a single biologist can tell you
whether a virus is alive or
or just a molecule an inert molecule
and you know whether the cell is the
first living entity i guess everybody
agrees but nobody can tell you why
and you know not everything that moves
breathes
not everything that breathes uh
reproduces
you know which is uh what i mentioned
the other day that the biologists
essentially look at reproduction only
out of all those and looks at number
seven and that's it does it reproduce or
doesn't it reproduce and i keep saying
you know my great grandmother she
doesn't reproduce
after the age of 60. you know and uh so
does that mean after the age of 60 she's
no longer alive because she doesn't
reproduce or is capable of reproducing
a woman that could not reproduce she's
dead you know she's inert
so no it's a bad um
definition when you have to include all
these
uh
capabilities all these
processes because not not all
living entities follow all of these
okay and if you follow three and you
don't follow four of them you know what
does that say about the definition
you need a definition that you can use
universally
and that's why we have our definition
here once again a live living a natural
object that moves against the path of
least resistance essentially right a
living being that has the ability to
move against gravity
and life is just a group of living
beings so if you're alive living
means you move
by yourself against the path of least
resistance primarily gravity
and um
if you can do that well then you're
alive and a group of living entities
then is uh what we call uh life okay
so is there life on this planet well yes
it is but it's not in rocks why because
rocks cannot move by themselves against
uh
gravity and it's got to be
essentially a um
you know we exclude all
entities made by man okay a little toy
airplane a little balloon that floats in
the air moves against gravity yeah it
doesn't count it's got to be a natural
entity not one made by man
and uh a lot of people have problems
with that but then they miss the point
because the point here is not to
play devil's advert kid for the
sake of playing devil's advocate we
don't define just for the sake of it we
define so that we have a useful
so we can use the definition
okay and so you
you can say well what if we include all
the artificial stuff that man makes you
know a robot that walks up a mountain
well yeah we made it and is that thing
alive well you know you can include all
artificial entities
what is the point of including within
the word alive or living
artificial entities do you have a
purpose for that we're not defining for
just for the sake of defining we're
defining so that we can use the word
okay in biology biology does not study
robots okay biology studies living
entities we need to know what a living
entity is and we're giving you a
definition anything that moves by itself
against gravity essentially
and that does not include you know
unnatural objects artificial objects it
only includes natural objects then we
can use it in biology
we can't use pixels we can't use um
airplanes balloons robots
little toy trucks we can't use any of
those
in biology
right so that's that's the bottom line
we're trying to define it for the
purposes of biology
okay
let's continue with physics move on to
physics here
and i was covering transparency and
opacity i gave five mechanisms i'll
review them very quickly okay and here
we have uh
five mechanisms variables that you
should keep in mind when you look at
things that are transparent or opaque
you're going to try to answer the
question of why is something opaque why
is something transparent
and the first criteria or the first
variable the first thing you have to
keep in mind when you do analysis is
alignment and we showed that with
polarization you can shine a laser
through two polarizing lenses as we show
there on the upper right upper left
and when you turn that at 90 degrees one
of the lenses with respect to the other
uh the um
it blocks the light you don't see the
light at the far
at the screen the black screen okay
there you see it and as soon as we turn
it
you don't okay so um transparency
apparently according to mother nature
has some or alignment has something to
do with transparency in some instances
it doesn't mean at all we're giving you
different
clues here how mother nature does
transparency and opacity
another one is quantity right at the
bottom you'll see there okay if we put
many uh sheets of this plastic thing
uh you can't see the candle the light on
the candle
if on the other hand you put just one
sheet
you can see a lot more
so the quantity of sheets also has a
bearing on
transparency and opacity
now one fella uh i'll stop here with
this uh talks about for the fourth time
i think talks about this talks about the
uh let me get back in here
uh talks about uh two-way mirror he says
a two-way mirror is half
silvered how it acts as has
nothing to do with molecular structure
of the glass
yeah nobody said it does
again i don't know if this fell
you know went to high school or what but
in high school you learn
that a molecule is not the same thing as
an atom and an atom
is what quantum mechanics works with
atom and below usually okay that's
that's the realm of quantum they want to
know what's happening in that invisible
subatomic world okay and i mentioned
that now three times so
you know i hope uh this guy's paying
attention anyways uh we're not talking
about molecules we're talking about
the atoms we're talking about the atomic
level okay
and it has nothing to do with glass
coating and it has nothing to do with
lighting in the room the question that
we have before us has nothing to do with
those two okay one more time
but you know this is like i think the
third or fourth time that i mentioned
this
the question before us
has nothing to do with uh whether the
glass is coding or not the question
before us has nothing to do with
lighting in the room when you have these
one-way mirrors
from one direction you see a mirror from
the other direction you see a glass
the person
that sees a mirror does not see the
person behind the glass
and the person who sees a glass sees the
person seeing himself in the mirror
okay
now people say well the coding man the
lighting in the room the question before
you has nothing to do with either one of
those variables
okay the question before you has nothing
to do with whether there's lighting in
the room or whether there's coding
on the
one-way mirror okay
and so what are we talking about what
what
what's the situation what is the
question
okay here's the question quantum
mechanics okay
uh provides no physical interpretation
for transparency or opacity the what
they give you is the following they say
there's a photon which is that little
red ball okay that comes and hits an
electron ball
okay
and because uh the electron ball absorbs
the energy the photon the whatever you
want to call that little ball a wave a
wave packet because it absorbs the
energy
of that little photon ball it jumps to a
higher energy level
if it does so if it absorbs that photon
the material
is opaque
in other words the photon does not go
through and reach your eye because it
was absorbed by the electron this is the
explanation that quantum mechanics gives
us let me repeat okay one more time we
have this electron at different energy
levels around
the nucleus of the atom
a photon comes in
it delivers its energy to the electron
if it's sufficient energy to knock the
electron from one energy level to a
higher energy level the photon is
absorbed and therefore the photon does
not go through to your eye and the
material is opaque
if instead
the electron absorbs the photon and
spits it back out or doesn't absorb it
at all because it it's not the photon
does not have enough energy to knock the
electron to a higher energy level then
the material is transparent
okay we got that so it's got to do with
atoms and not with molecules and it's
got to do with whether the photon has
enough energy to knock that electron to
a higher energy level that's
the explanation
now what's the problem with that well
the first problem is that you know there
are no such things as particles in
quantum mechanics
the famous particle is not a particle
particle is a misleading world were very
misleading because what they're talking
about is point particles meaning point
nothings because they're really talking
about a concept known as the wave
function collapse so what they're moving
there those yellow balls that you see
moving there under the word particles
those are wave function collapses what
they're looking what you're staring at
is a bunch of numbers really that are
flowing and they represent those numbers
with little balls
supposedly
representing locations and locations of
what well it's just locations you have
no physical object in any of those
locations okay so that's the first
problem and they also use the wave
whenever they run into trouble there's
no such thing as a wave first in the
standard model of quantum mechanics
and then we have a separate problem or
more fundamental problem which is the
fact that those blue and red arrows
those are vectors they have magnitude
and direction and what the
mathematicians have done they set them
in motion so what you're staring at is
the flow of vectors the flow of
magnitude and direction what is
magnitude it's a number uh what you're
seeing is a flowing of number fives and
sixes
so we don't have a physical
interpretation to what quantum mechanics
offers uh for uh transparency or opacity
because
there is no physical object
that's why okay so that's where we start
but the mechanism that they uh that
quantum mechanics proposes is the one
you see at the top photon comes in
knocks the electron to a higher energy
level in that case the material is
opaque and if it doesn't have the energy
to do that if the photon cannot knock
that electron to a higher energy level
the material is transparent the photon
goes through and reaches your eye
okay
okay um
so what's the problem with this with
just the explanation assuming we concede
the particles okay well here's the
problem okay the problem is that we have
this one-way mirror okay and the man
on the upper left there
he looks at the mirror and he sees
himself he doesn't see the lady who's on
the other side of the mirror
the lady looks and she sees right
through
the mirror because she's looking
actually through a glass and she sees
the man
so the man sees himself in a mirror
whereas the woman sees the man
so now we perform a little experiment
and what we do we take two lasers okay
we take the lasers and put them on each
side of that mirror
on the one hand
we have the laser on the man's side and
that just reflects the light back to you
you see a little dot
on the uh
on the mirror
and you can and that's all you see
on the other hand the lady uh
she sees uh the man's thought uh the
man's laser come to her eye
and if she points her laser
it hits uh a brick wall
okay so the light from from the man
uh the laser light goes through and is
seen by the woman but the light that the
woman sends is not seen by the man
okay that's the issue now has the mirror
changed in any way
we have the same mirror
in either direction the same material
okay this is not an issue of molecules
again is it an issue of atoms remember
what was the mechanism that the photon
from the lasers is absorbed by the
electrons that form the mirror
okay and in either direction we have the
same material
okay so the photon should be absorbed
from the laser should be absorbed by the
electrons in the mirror in either
direction
but it's not it's only one way
and that's what you have to answer so
here it is in more detail okay
and so the question is you know here we
have the laser
that comes from the left okay from the
man that one goes through
it goes through the atom we only put one
atom just so that people have it very
simple okay that green arrow just goes
through whereas the one from the
absorbed side you know that one is
absorbed
by the same atom by the same electron
and so the question is why why
does the energy the photon whatever you
want to call it go through from left to
right and does not go through from right
to left
this is the question you have to answer
okay and so uh it's got nothing to do
with the lighting in the room it's got
nothing to do with the coating on the
mirror because the material is the same
in either direction
okay the the photons should be absorbed
by the same by one atom we're just going
to look at one atom in that mirror and
that atom in that mirror should absorb
in either direction why does that atom
only absorb in one direction and not in
the other that's what you gotta answer
if you don't have uh
an answer for that then you simply are
alluding the question okay
so uh i rest my case on that if a person
wants to answer he can answer
otherwise he's got to run with his tail
between his legs like he has now for
three sessions
okay um another file raises issues here
related to this is those empirical demos
of alignment quantity temperature
stiffness of your frequency are extra
scientific as you always said
well again you know i point with my
finger at the moon the guy staring at my
finger instead of looking at the moon
he's confusing
experiments
with the mechanisms i'm providing for
for how mother nature does
uh opacity and transparency okay i'm
looking at the variables
see if this enters his head
i'm looking at the variables that mother
nature is using under different
circumstances you have to figure out
which ones of these she uses for glass
which one she uses for water which one
she uses for air to produce transparency
in those materials and which one she
uses to produce opacity like you know
brick wall
how does she do this well i'm giving you
the clues the things it's not that we're
running an experiment
but see again i point to the moon
they're staring at my finger you know
this is not about experiments
this has to do with the mechanisms that
give you an idea okay
what how mother nature could be doing
transparency in opacity
and these are the variables the things
that you got to look at and the things
you have to consider if you're going to
answer the question
and i doubt very much this gentleman can
answer that question anyways
uh because he's still staring at my
finger
okay so continuing here we have
temperature
on
on the upper side but see all these
three on the right hand side are kind of
related because stiffness is a function
of temperature and temperature is a
function of frequency okay
and so
all these three are kind of related but
it gives you an idea what to look for
again for transparency and opacity in
the case of temperature i showed the
case where glass
full of
water is frozen and when it's frozen in
you know you can't see the pen
it's only when the
glass is melted that oh i'm sorry the
ice is melted that you can see right
through and see the pan through the
water so there's a difference between
the water being cold and the water being
in liquid state
but when fell pointed out that what
you're doing is freezing a lot of oxygen
molecules
irrelevant really because the point here
is that
even even in the case of oxygen you know
oxygen when it's frozen it becomes uh
invisible not invisible but
there's a tendency for it to become
opaque and then i showed the opposite
with argon showing that when you have
argon in a solid and liquid state it
tends to be transparent whereas when
it's in a gaseous state primarily in a
plasma state well at that point it gets
violent
and so uh and so it's opaque so it's in
reverse for argon and so what you got to
do is look at temperature as a you know
as a factor that affects opacity and
transparency that's against what we're
trying to do here we're trying to
show you all the things to keep in mind
another one is stiffness which is again
related to temperature and you have a
solid
crystal structure like you see there in
a
center and you have the other one which
is a gaseous state could be air or
whatever and
again it tends to be more transparent
the less stiff it is in general okay so
stiffness is one of the criteria you
have to think about when you're looking
at transparency and opacity
and the last one we covered was
frequency and you can't do that with
waves because again there's no physical
object called wave okay and we replace
that with a rope and with a rope yes you
can talk about um
you know the link lengths
and
what we held is that the longer the link
the colder it is meaning now we go to
temperature up at the top and the
stiffer it is and we go down the middle
there okay so if you make the links
longer you have a colder uh
rope
or colder material
vibrates less it gets stiff
and the stiffer it is it tends to be
opaque
and vice versa the hotter it is the
shorter the links
the more energy you could say in terms
of mathematics uh the higher the
frequency and so what happens is now uh
it tends to be more transparent
so that's
a summary of
what we covered okay these are things
for you to look at and figure out which
ones of these variables these factors
affect transparency and opacity when
you're analyzing you know transparency
of air water
uh glass etc
okay um
but today we're going to add a couple
more and it's going to be this one
distance
and speed and the question is does
distance
does speed affect transparency or
opacity the fact that something is very
far away
like a glass you know if it's close by
to your nose
is it more transparent
than if that same glass were farther
away
see in one case if you have it close to
your face you can see through that glass
you're not paying attention to the glass
you're paying attention to the tree that
you're staring at it's like the glass
does not exist
but as you separate the glass and put it
farther away from your face
closer to the tree for example
uh does that uh the fact that that glass
is now distant from your eye does that
affect the opacity
of your ability to see through the glass
i mean now you have distance between
your eye and the glass okay that's
that's what i'm suggesting here and so
let's start at the beginning here with
this and here it is you see a curve a
light versus distance
and you can see that
light
tends to
become
the intensity of light tends to reduce
the farther the light
is and this has to do
with what they call the inverse square
law this light intensity falls off
as the inverse square of the distance
they call it a law
uh
you know so intensity falls off
and so the question is does this have
anything at all to do with transparency
and opacity
okay and again it's for you to ponder
these questions to see if
it's worth including within the
variables that you're going to
factor into your analysis of transparent
material
and here let me give you a for instance
of something you may want to look at
okay and here you have three pictures
and i want you to look at the
little sign there the chevron sign in
red that i've circled in red
well you can't read uh the letters there
okay you're looking through the
uh windshield of a car
and you're approaching you can't see the
letters there you can barely see the
sign
okay
well what happens when you come near
well it suddenly becomes a little
more visible okay you can see better now
and again it has to do a little bit with
the distance right
does it have anything to do with the
glass that you're staring through
and the nearer you get
you get a little near now you can see
the letters of the chevron sign okay
um
so
the distance uh make a change
and you would say yeah i made the change
as far as seeing the sign does that mean
it had anything to do with the
windshield itself
which is the material we're analyzing
here right we're analyzing whether the
windshield has a transparency of the
windshield has something to do with
distance
okay and let me show you
uh something else that you probably
missed by looking at these pictures and
that's this
um
here you can see
that
the sky
was bluer uh when it was closer to you
than when it was farther away in other
words
as you move
in that direction what you're seeing is
that the sky
is becoming
a bluer
and is that because there's this
overhang bridge that you're going
through is that why that's that case
or has it to do with the windshield
itself
okay
and you can see other things in that
picture like for example that tree
that's close to the chevron sign
uh you can barely see it it's a
kind of nebulous in the upper picture
but as you get closer you can see it
more vividly okay
and again is this a question
of
does this have anything to do with the
windshield at all or does it have to do
simply with the distance
from your eye to the thing that you're
observing through the windshield
okay factors again to consider okay all
i'm throwing in there is all these
factors so that you ponder if they have
anything at all to do with transparency
or opacity
okay let's look at speed okay
speed of light is known to be little c
uh according to einstein according to me
too uh light is a constant
light travels always
at
little c and 300 000 kilometers per
second
now that's not exactly what einstein's
disciple
believed today they believe that
light changes speed depending on the
medium it goes through
because they think it goes through
things
okay
so the way they look at it the more
opaque
an object is
the slower that the little photon ball
or whatever that photon thing is
uh
goes through it
okay
and uh here we have the famous case of
the prism
we have white light coming in it hits
the prism
and it breaks down into different colors
coming out at the other side
and so the question is how does it
mother nature do that magic trick
well the way it's explained today is
that light travels slower
when it comes out because it's like if
it hit a brick wall again it's the
stiffness you can say the crystal
structure
of this material such that you know
light
hits and have these little balls ping
pong balls
you're supposed to think of them as such
like little balls because that's what
they illustrate
and
these little balls hit the side of the
prism go through the material refract
right and then come out of the other
side also in a refractive angle
and but they don't come out as a white
light they come out broken up into
different colors
okay so the question is how does mother
nature do that trick this is a
transparent material it's translucent
we're always going to use the word
transparent okay
it's transparent allows light to go
through and so does light go through is
it a little ball that's going through
the whole
uh material and coming out the other end
and if it comes out the other end
okay we can understand it's coming out
slower because it hit a material which
is has a solid crystal structure so it
slows it down
let's concede that okay
[Music]
now those light go travel at a different
speed coming out
does a red color coming out or blue
color coming out do they have different
speeds
does red light travel slower than blue
light uh slower than uh white light or
do they all travel at the same speed
with that conversion factor that you see
there where frequency exchanges for
wavelength
now we can do that with a rope very
simple you know i've shown this many
times you know uh links
uh are very small when it's very tight
and when you unwind you have
uh longer links and fewer links that's
what that equation says
how do you do that with particles
how do you explain that with waves why
doesn't the wave
get bigger
longer you know and also have more waves
passing through a given point
speed of light right we're changing the
speed of light we're saying that light
travels faster
or slower
right
uh attack dance travels faster uh
horse travels slower
whatever
or uh
ocean wave travels slower right
so the question is you know you can't
explain this transparency with particles
and waves until first you identify the
physical object that is doing the waving
in the case of particles there's nothing
to explain because it's zero dimensional
particle point particle
it's not even a particle it's a concept
which they turned into a particle or
represent with a particle so the
particle is dead quantum can has no
explanation with particles because they
don't have a particle to begin with a
corpuscle
waves waves again is there's no physical
object called wave so we can't explain
it with wave but assuming we did explain
it with waves why doesn't the wave
travel faster or slower right
and why doesn't the wave um
you know also get longer or shorter
because if the wave can get longer
and travel at the same speed
then it's traveling faster than light
okay because
now if you multiply longer wavelength
time the same frequency
right then you get a faster speed of
light and vice versa if you increase the
frequency and leave the wavelength alone
you also get a faster speed of light
and if you increase both frequency and
wavelength i don't see any reason why
you can't increase both right why would
why would you not be able to increase
both the frequency and the wavelength
okay you increase the wavelength and
passing through a given point it passes
you know at a faster frequency why can't
you do that
you can't even do that with a particle
you i mean you can increase both the
frequency and the wavelength you got
faster speed of light
and so why can't we do that why can't we
travel faster in light
and for some reason you know i said you
know the speed of light at least in a
vacuum is constant
you can't uh can't change it and so what
they did they created uh for materials
what is known as refractive index a
conversion table that has to do with uh
opacity with how um
how whatever material there is there
slows
light down
and if that's the case if it slows light
down and we get colors coming out the
other end
do those colors of light the red light
the blue light whatever comes out green
light
do they travel at different speeds
or do we have the same speed of light
coming out
and if so
because there's another question if so
if light had to go through
the prism and it was slowed down by the
prism
what accelerated light when it came out
to the point where now it travels again
at the speed of light like if we had
that prism in in outer space right we
shine a light
on the prism we have vacuum and vacuum
on on the outside of the prism
it travels the light travels slower
through the prism let's concede that
okay so travel slower what speeds it
back up when it comes out back into
space
why does it travel back at little c
300 000 kilometers per second once it
comes out the other side of the prism
okay so all these questions have to be
answered with a rope no problem you have
a white light which is a whole bunch of
ropes
right it's a
menagerie of
many uh
ropes coming into the prism and when
they go from one atom to another atom to
another atom the relay process well uh
they don't lose speed
what they change is frequency in
exchange for wave
and when they come out because they
can't come out of different from
different atoms that are coming out well
then it's not that each one travels
slower or faster they always travel at
little c even through the prism it's
always like always no matter what
material in the universe it always
travels at little c between any two
atoms the only thing that changes is the
wavelength in exchange for the frequency
and so when the wavelength is longer you
have smaller frequency meaning fewer
links
on the rope
and when the links are shorter you have
more links greater frequency
very straightforward simple we're done
we have an explanation for transparency
through a prism
okay
and here's uh something that uh
kind of uh reinforces that okay it's the
harvard tower experiment
uh
the two two fellows uh pounded replica
in 1959 i think it was
what they did was
they went in there and they uh
threw a laser i think i'm not sure if it
was a laser but they did send a high
frequency light that's what it was high
frequency light and i think they send it
downwards from the top of the tower
harvard tower down to the basement where
the detector was
and what happened was they realized that
the frequency increased
okay
meaning that the wavelength got
wet shorter right
and vice versa if you reverse the
experiments and send the beam upwards
okay to the harbor tower it would
receive the opposite you would see that
maybe you have gamma ray coming out or
whatever
high frequency
signal you send out and as it gets to
the top of the tower you're going to
measure it at a
longer wavelength and lower frequency
well what what you've just described is
a rope because when you take a rope and
you know you tied in
i don't know to a telephone post
and you stretch it out
as long as you want to the end of the
street you'll see that the links closer
to the telephone post are shorter and as
the rope is extended all the way out the
lists become longer and you have fewer
links okay and that's what i'm trying to
show there that's in general the case
and that's i think what the tower
experiment harvard tower experiment
showed okay that uh as light attempts to
um
to leave the earth okay
and the same thing would apply to the
sun by the way any light coming out any
rope coming out of the sun extending out
from the sun
as it uh extends outwards
to another star system to another galaxy
uh the links get longer
as we go move outwards from whatever in
this case the sun or the earth it
wouldn't matter what so the link should
get longer
okay and here i'm that's the theory okay
for you to ponder
and here let me show you a little graph
that puts that into the right uh
perspective okay here you have the sun
and what you have is gamma rays coming
out of the sun very high frequency rays
okay
short
uh
wavelength
link lengths in the case of the rope
and only as you move out do the links
get longer okay
so a rope that starts in um
atom of the sun that ends
in an atom of the earth
would uh
would not have enough length that whole
rope would not have enough length to
have such long
links
as one that for example um
like the one on the top
extends to another star or another
galaxy
if that atom is connected to an atom in
the
in another galaxy the links will become
longer only
much further out
and
the suggestion here is that the gamma
rays that we receive here on earth from
the sun are not of atoms that are
connected to
atoms of the earth okay they are atoms
that contain that
are very far away and those gamma rays
just come through the earth and continue
going all the way to whatever object
that rope is tied to okay
so
this is the theory i'm proposing maybe
someone has a better idea but this is
what i think is happening out there i
think that the gamma rays that reach the
earth are not atoms that are
the
the rope does not end in an atom that
is
part of the earth okay
that's my
five cents worth on that okay
okay uh let me just show you some of the
conclusions okay
um
does distance affect opacity
transparency for visible light in other
word comes to your eyes okay
uh so
i'm not telling you i'm asking you
okay
and is it the same to see through a
window that is nearby you know like tied
to your eyes when you see the tree
through that window
the same thing as if that window we're
close to the tree far away and you're
looking through that window at the tree
okay is there a difference that
does the distance affect you opacity of
the material
through which
visible light comes through
okay
uh
you can even shine a laser you know try
it with a laser
and have someone close to the tree or or
some kind of uh screen there to tell you
whether
the laser is the same size or the same
intensity as it was when you had the
glass close to the laser okay that's an
experiment anyone can do okay and more
or less get an idea of
how to answer that question
okay and then the speed of light is
constant
always travels at little c never changes
at speed no matter what why because it's
a rope
so all it does is change this frequency
for wavelength wavelength for frequency
higher the frequency lower the
wavelength in other words the link
length the length of a link
and you know the the shorter the link
the more links frequency that you get
very simple very straightforward c
equals frequency times wavelength is the
equation of a rope there is no other
object you can imagine that can simulate
that equation it's got to be a rope and
it's been confirmed little c is
300 000 kilometers per second and more
or less rounding off and
it is a constant at least they claim
it's a constant in vacuum very little
difference with air even though there is
a slight difference
uh according to quantum mechanics in
speed okay i'm saying the speed is the
same it's just that one atom is relaying
to another atom through there and
there's refraction and all kinds of good
stuff in there as well okay
okay uh prism is transparent we can call
it translucent i call i use the word
transparent so keep it simple
and prism does not
change speed of light
okay what we have is one atom connected
to another it's relaying the signal it
receives at the speed of light from one
atom to another so it's a relay race
okay
and what you're relaying is torsion
a signal that you receive
and prism exchanges frequency number of
links for link length okay and again uh
quantum mechanics has no answer to these
questions because quantum mechanics does
not have a physical object to begin with
whether particles or waves whichever one
it uses there is no physical object yet
in front of us
okay
okay so uh we end with this the notion
that we had for
the the different variables that we
wanted to
factor when we analyze transparency and
opacity okay and we're going to continue
with a certain subject related to all
this next time around
meanwhile let's move on to
the questions that we've had since last
time questions and comments
fellow says says uh scientific method
checking a bunch of dictionaries
okay well when i check these
dictionaries you know i find always the
same nonsense i find that um
see if i can see it here
this is what i find the method of
research and persuasion i don't find a
scientific method i find
persuasion that's what i find they say
that you observe okay you observe so you
look at something is that science
you make a prediction
is that science just make a prediction
uh that you know
a horse is going to win on saturday is
that what they call science physics
they run an experiment uh
to confirm or verify the prediction the
behavior the description okay okay so
you run an experiment you let go of the
pen it falls to the ground okay what did
we learn by running an experiment well
not much all we did was run an
experiment without understanding
anything
they make a measurement okay so you take
a measure you measure the table and
measure one meter is that science
you will measure it again measure one
meter and one centimeter you measured
wrong the first time okay so now you
have more accuracy does that make you a
scientist because you measure the table
okay you collect data for evidence
what's the purpose of evidence well it's
to persuade the jury
so we're talking about belief here
okay
and then you describe it with an
equation okay that's a description
okay so far you all you did was describe
a chair and say it's got four legs one
uh backrest one seat
is just describing that mathematically
you know one plus one plus four is that
what a chair is
is that science because you you
described it with an equation
uh you discover a novel behavior great
you present evidence again to present
the jurors okay your your buddies your
peers you ask them to vote to see if
they like your theory okay and they vote
and maybe they vote in your favor great
uh whatever results you get we call that
they call it knowledge
okay now this means now you have uh you
know uh this knowledge
you're
suddenly you're you're like the uh
there's a scarecrow when he's given the
brain suddenly you can do mathematical
calculations
[Laughter]
then repeat the process to confirm the
knowledge okay somebody else repeats
this whole thing
then you invent a gadget to prove the
theory so you make a computer and say
well that proves quantum mechanics
because i have a computer
well you know we invent gadgets by trial
and error we don't need to
understand how uh
a field works or uh how energy what
energy is or what mass is we don't need
to understand any of that and we can
still have in fact we do have all kinds
of technology without understanding
any of those they don't even know what a
magnetic field is and what what physical
object is in that world we call magnetic
field and if you can't tell me that you
can't give me a physical interpretation
does that mean you cannot make a
computer
which uses magnetic fields
obviously you know the the fact that you
can make a device such as a computer has
nothing to do with your understanding of
what a magnetic field is
so uh and then you award a prize to
certify knowledge well none of that uh
has anything to do with science all of
that is just research and persuasion
nothing but
now science is what you see on the right
we need to explain
that's what people want to know they
want to know an explanation of how
magnetism works how electricity works
how gravity works that's what people
want to understand that's what people
associate with physics and you want
proof go to quora and you'll find all
kinds of questions related to those
kinds of subjects people want to know
what gravity is how gravity works
they want to know why the earth doesn't
fly out of the solar system they want to
see a picture of a real atom
does that mean you have to observe it uh
or does it mean that you have to
visualize it
and so there's a difference there you
know you can visualize without having
proven without having
seen it
all you need to do is visualize it so
that you can give an explanation based
on your model
and so no you don't have to use your
eyes a blind man can do physics
quadriplegic can do physics without
using his arms you know legs whatever
okay so what is the scientific method
well we have a hypothesis which is known
as assumptions hypothesis is just a
bunch of assumptions the assumptions
include the objects that you're going to
use
okay to do your theory you have to have
objects you can't do physics without an
object if there were absolutely nothing
in the universe you would not be able to
do physics okay there's nothing to watch
nothing to see nothing to do experiment
sound for that matter right
okay then you have to have the set of
definitions okay
and what are those well you have to have
definitions for that you have to define
what a definition is a scientific
definition as opposed to a definition of
ordinary speech
the words you find in the ordinary
dictionary are usually no good
for physics
for science
okay then you just have the initial
scene okay first frames
and we call that the statement of the
facts
it's not the facts
it's a statement of the facts the facts
only mother nature knows exactly what
happened okay what we can do is tell the
jurors we say look
this is the way i
think things happened and based on your
starting point on those on that
statement of the facts that's what
you're going to base your theory on and
so the
jury can follow your train of thought
because you've given them the
the foundations for your theory
and then of course you go into the
mechanisms and causes that's what
concerns physics so yeah what you see in
the dictionary is not the scientific
method okay
uh what you see is the method of
persuasion which is known as religion
and that's what mathematical physics has
been doing for the last 400 years all
they've been doing is
experiments
uh equations measurements equations
observations and then ridiculous
explanations for how this universe works
you know
particle can be at two places at once uh
the reason the earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system is because of warped
time
so yeah
the scientific method so-called
scientific method that you find out
there the one he wants me to read in the
dictionaries that one has produced the
most idiotic the most irrational
explanations you can imagine
so no it doesn't work uh the the proof
is
in the pudding
okay okay another fellow says says uh
i'm talking about multiple ropes you're
talking about this scissors movement
okay he says that uh
when you close the scissor pair of
scissors okay the blades come together
and as they come together
there's this imaginary line between the
two scissors that moves faster than the
two blades move closer to each other
so if you're assuming
that there's a physical object there
right a little dot
that's moving along the the edges of the
two blades coming together okay that
that speed
he says is faster than the movement of
the blades
so he's making that comparison he says
well if two things move closer to each
other
that speed of that imaginary whatever
that concept that nothingness
he says is faster than light
great
okay and that's right now we're the
sleeves so he says i'm talking about
multiple ropes each of whose ends travel
slower than light okay but the
intersection of those ropes the neutron
he says okay
not really but he says uh the
intersection of those ropes according to
rope hypothesis okay the the theory that
i'm proposing is what appears
seems appears right
as an illusory uh
object
okay yeah there's no object but and it
is an illusion it's an optical illusion
that he's referring to a mirage even
states it's a mirage yeah to travel
faster than any part of the rope okay so
[Laughter]
yeah so the scissor the imaginary what
mirage uh illusory
object uh travels faster than uh
than the scissors when the scissors
close
great okay
i think he
he probably broke his brain on this one
you know uh as the ropes shift around
due to motion of the atoms they are
connected to okay thus
under all the assumptions about the
thread you have laid out over the years
there are certainly neutrons in the rope
hypothesis that necessarily travel
faster than light
my god poor fellow
okay let's uh answer him
okay here it is
uh here's our neutron a bunch of ropes
okay just a two-dimensional version of
it okay
and what do we have a neutron is a
convergence of many ropes electron
magnetic robes coming from every atom in
the universe they converge upon a point
they criss-cross they continue rolling
because they're going to other atoms and
where all these ropes meet we call that
a neutron and that neutron has a
radius
of
the size of a
hydrogen atom okay so where the electron
shell is around the hydrogen atom that's
more or less where we chop off the
neutron arbitrarily that's the size of a
neutron
and it more or less has the same
mass as a proton and an electron
as an a hydrogen atom okay
and then uh
in my book i show how a neutron converts
to an atom and an atom to a neutron
which is what is this decay is about but
i'm not going to get into that now if
the edges of two ropes act like blades
of a scissor right if if you have two
ropes two of these ropes and they come
to each other
the line that goes between them
obviously is going to travel faster than
mine i don't care how fast these two
things are going closer to each other
at some point you could conceive that
the line that's moving between them is
moving faster than light right that's
what this file is addressing
the optical illusion
this is an optical illusion he's
comparing an optical illusion he calls
it a neutron somehow
of a line or space disappearing faster
than light between the two ropes right
has nothing to do with the speed of the
entire neutron which is that whole ball
okay
and
sliding along ropes
so where he got this idea that a neutron
in under rope model travels faster than
lion well he's going to have to explain
that and he cannot talk about two
ropes of a neutron neutron is a bunch of
ropes not two ropes that's the first
thing
and second if if
two ropes come together because they're
tied to some kind of atom out there that
they come together and the space between
those two ropes
you know travels faster
perpendicular to the motion of the two
ropes faster than light what's that got
to do with the motion of the neutron
itself
it's got nothing to do with the motion
of the entire neutron
so again either he specifies exactly
what he's talking about
uh
or
[Music]
i'm not sure even he can do that
but well we'll let him answer if he's
got some other
better explanation
or
or he can phrase this question in a more
precise way then maybe we can address it
but right now uh
he's come he's comparing apples and
point particles
that's what he's doing
he's talking about a mirage he himself
said it yeah it's an optical illusion
okay another fellow says uh the
following he i think he got this from
another website now that he presented
the rope model there for some reason and
this is what someone answered him so he
brought it back to me
he says dark matter if the galaxy is
like a spider web okay we have that
spider web
uh
you can imagine that uh you know all the
atoms in a galaxy are interconnected all
the stars are interconnected so it's
like if you had a spider web
interconnecting the whole galaxy and the
whole thing rotates like a single
platform like a carousel okay
and so if the galaxy is like a spider
web yeah
the inner plants move so slowly should
break apart the web
i have no idea how they concluded that
but you know again
people have to come up with a little
more detail than that because i don't
know how they concluded that
this is just a conclusion of someone who
doesn't understand the rope model okay i
have no idea why the
fact that planets move at a given speed
has anything to do with the
interconnectivity
of the entire galaxy of all the stars in
the galaxy and all the atoms by the way
okay uh another question comes from a
flat earther i i always love to have
flat earthers busy here
okay flatter says explain why is there
no test that anyone can do that shows
the physical earth
is rotating or moving in any way
yeah
the earth is not moving except when i
drink too much then maybe the earth
starts moving underneath my feet okay
and so he wants a test some kind of
experiment okay what you believe about
the physical earth moving is obviously
wrong
which you can prove just by driving your
car in different directions
with or without drinking and driving you
know you shouldn't do that right the
physical earth is stationary
see
the answer to his question is very
simple it's uh you don't do experiments
in science because when you do
experiments in science you fool people
like this fellow who thinks that
experiments have something to do with
science and because of it he reaches the
wrong conclusions
he says well the earth is not moving
because the floor underneath my feet i
don't feel it moving and that's the only
experiment i need to show
that the earth is moving
okay
and so what are you gonna tell them you
know uh yeah
just drink some vodka and uh you know
maybe a whole bottle and then you'll see
you're shaking underneath your feet and
then you'll say oh yeah the earth is
moving but only when i drink
yeah we don't do experiments because
they mislead people like him into
believing that they've proven
that the earth does not move because i
ran an experiment the earth did not move
underneath my feet
okay good
uh
love the flat earthers
great people
okay and uh final issue if i'll says you
often speak of how the particle and wave
model of quantum mechanic physics is
wrong but how did i didn't say it wrong
by the way it's not wrong it's
irrational
wrong is an opinion right wrong
whatever's right for me is wrong for you
and so on
that's an opinion we're not talking
about opinions we're talking about
irrationality
why is it irrational the number one
criterion
for irrationality converting concepts
into objects reification
you take love and you turn it into a
heart
you take uh
energy
and turn it i don't know into a ghost
spirit
uh you take space-time
and you turn it into a net
to a fishnet
that's irrational
a particle can be in two places at once
in quantum that's irrational so no
quantum is not wrong
okay i want to make always clear i
always cl make sure everybody
understands it it's not wrong it's
irrational okay you cannot understand it
and that's why mr uh richard feynman
said no one understands quantum
mechanics
no kidding
but how does the rope hypothesis deal
with something like the double slit
experiment and seeming wave particle
duality that results from this well i
sent the fellow a link so that he can
see the
i have a video on the slit experiment
you can find it in some of the videos
there that we have
and uh essentially uh what happens is
you see the ropes there connected to the
sides
of a needle okay so if you take a needle
you have atoms on both sides of the
needle
and what the rope does is the signal
from the source could be a laser
uh gets relayed by those two atoms to
the screen
and then it's just a question of how
off they are they could be off by half a
link by a quarter link by
full link okay so if they're off by by
partial by portions of a link then you
have more and more destructive
interference only when they meet
with the right with the exact phase do
you have a
uh constructive interference and you
have light
okay that's essentially it but again
it's better to watch the video
a video is worth a billion words
with that i'll see you next time on
wednesday and we're going to continue
with a subject related to what we
covered today
and uh but we begin a new series now
we'll see you then we'll see you on
wednesday bye